to this one Richard report less than
five minutes on the clock against Magnus
Carlsen with only a little over three
minutes his hoodie on looks a little
cold for Magnus Carlsen and on the board
does this look like a draw right now
possibly but there's still a lot of life
left in this one ah so it's level
material uh White has the bishop pair
but Black's pieces are very active I
love Black's Bishop in the center of the
board
um it looks a bit scary allowing some
checks the White Queen can go to the top
of the board and check the black king
but the Black Knight will just drop back
and defend
poof
it's hard to evaluate to be honest if
anything unless white has something
immediate I would probably choose black
I
could deal yeah
yeah save that electricity oh all right
we have a reaction on the bar yeah I I'm
extremely surprised by this move okay
Magnus was threatening the Knight but
surely you flick in the check to make
the Black Knight go passive first and
then play Knight H4 because now what can
happen is this Knight can spring out to
G5 in a bunch of lines and this F3
Square David if you want to highlight it
uh can be very very tender and this is
totally weird what Rapport is doing and
it doesn't surprise me at all that the
bar has gone completely insane of a
Magnus this bishop is just a terrible
piece this bishop is a potential monster
so surely we don't let them both
disappear from the board for example if
you take the White Knight will come back
and capture and uh White should be fine
here maybe
but uh actually even in this type of
position you have to worry about the
black queen coming in attacking this
Pawn this pawn and this Pawn uh this one
is a bit complicated but Lawrence you
were talking about the potential of the
light squares and he actually uses that
square you highlighted in this position
he dropped back with his Bishop
um if this bishop is captured of course
the black queen just
creates all sorts of chaos and uh if the
bishop isn't captured White's Bishop has
to move
again you could flick in this check
forcing the Black Knight back but once
you move your Bishop wherever you go
very least black can just come and
capture a report right
just a free porn and uh black still has
that kind of potential on these light
squares around the white king later and
the white king very very weak
yeah yeah it's just weird to do this for
Richard he had other Alternatives safer
Alternatives and uh in the current
position
did you take this Knight do you move
your Bishop either way it looks like
you're losing at least a pawn
for reports and okay look at his face
now he's realizing he's he's messed it
up slightly he is a kind of a momentaro
kind of player isn't he in terms of
style it's just crazy moves all the time
do you think he is even if it doesn't
look good on the bar he is you know
having fun in this situation doesn't
look like his type of position again
because for black there's minimal risk
um report likes it when he can either
attack or where he can kind of push or
bully his opponent into a strategically
inferior position because actually
technically Rapport he's very good at
end games very good at strategy he just
hides that behind weird wonderful moves
so here white is the one struggling
strategically and I think dynamically in
this exact position okay it's the white
king that's actually more vulnerable
than the black king and Rapport
struggles there so okay he drops his
Bishop back and black does indeed go and
grab a pawn like some Pawn up and the
black Queen's ready to swoop into some
light squares later on a lot of
pieces on that
each line right now
it's true
a whole bunch yeah just need to put the
White Queen here put it back in here
have you ever seen that all have you
seen that in the chess game though you
can recall one line just filled up yeah
once okay one Sunday was the center line
that had like two nights two nights and
then the queen yeah it was quite
impressive yeah but not all the pieces
because
unfortunately that's not possible no I
can only have eight yeah how many pawns
have you seen like we've all seen triple
Bones have you ever seen quadruple Pawns
I've seen one where white for example
has pawns on E2 E3 E4 and then black has
E7 E6 but never like the whole that
would be amazing to get the whole column
blocked with pawns that would be great
but hey how can you do it I don't know
creative
be creative yeah rubble's gonna have to
be creative if he's gonna somehow
Miracle a half Point here but what an
odd what if for somebody strong and
that's you know that's Richard's problem
you know he's he's a genius he's
actually changed his style Kaya so his
craziness isn't he was crazy and he will
admittedly say like I remember
less than 10 years ago something like
five six seven years ago he was still
playing open tournaments
um
look at that move that's that just
appeared on the board what is what what
what looks like a mouse looks like my
move from the blitz tournament earlier
today this is clever right
I mean we don't know if it works but the
evaluation Bar says no but in this
position with his Knight attacked he
just ignored it and yeah you push a pawn
to a square it can be taken twice
doesn't work GH4 and H3 how about that
that might be the color blue Lawrence I
think you're right if you take the
Knight White's idea is that after Pawn
takes Pawn uh if the black porn
recaptures then suddenly White's Bishop
breaks free onto this line and this
Knight is actually doomed
um so white just needs to use his Bishop
to attack the Black Knight Bishop H6
I've landed oh wait
oh wait this is actually no but this is
a nice idea and now the queen does take
the Knight anyway
uh
uh okay so what could the idea be
because suddenly I mean Black's King is
getting checkmated of anything could you
be really clinical about things and just
uh try and trade of Queens okay so okay
he's grabbed this Pawn First
um so Ivanka you were thinking about
maybe just using the black queen and
yeah offering a trade makes sense black
captured this Pawn instead and
again this idea giving up a second Port
now to distract and uh
suddenly this would be a deadly attack
but Magnus he's not afraid of ghosts he
just pushes forward and he's trying to
make a new Queen
I think this is good enough it looks
like he's quick enough here uh to push
his Pawn because for example if white
tries the same idea going for this
Checkmate I think he can just promote
anyway it's just one check the Knight
drops off and blacks Queen defends
everything Black's actually going to be
checkmating uh White in the corner using
both of his Queens right now hmm
I think Magnus has found the way he's
just gonna push his Pawn
and okay in the current position still
crazy still fighting Rapport offering
this trade of Queens
but now maybe you can just uh can you
trade off the Queens make a new queen of
your own for example uh queen queen
oh this idea is still on the cards if uh
the Knight is captured then Bishop takes
porn
still some ideas oh so complicated this
current position both sides about to
make uh I mean you could see a Trader
queens and then you Queens appear on the
board but oh what a classy move yeah
really sophisticated just defending the
black queen you're ready to make a new
one anytime you want in a rush aha
looking good for minus 28 on the bar and
if he wins this game he will be on 10
points Magnus Carlsen that will be the
same as Abdul satoro because he just
lost his first game today the tournament
leader before the start of today losing
in game one against read it
we will have several players on 10
points after this round this is looking
to be a very bloody round actually Kai
if we if we if you take a quick look at
the results so far
we've got gukesh winning vidit winning
Magnus just want to win just one Kmart
winning Gary winning duda's gonna win
an absolutely Savage round wow